what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it does indeed look like Sony is
making some moves with their
spider-verse which is something that
we've wanted them to do but could be a
good thing or a bad thing today we have
some news about a live-action Miles
Morales coming to the MCU we have some
news about Tom Holland Spider-Man and of
course the upcoming across the
spider-verse movie and it looks like
everything might actually be connecting
especially with the upcoming Madame web
film which is supposed to be a
Multiverse or spider-verse film that
Sony is planning on doing so it does
seem like they do have a plan over the
years we have talked about how Sony and
their spiderverse that they are creating
has the potential to be something great
which is true they do have the potential
to create a marvelous Spider-Man
universe that involves the Multiverse
aka the spider verse because it is the
spider-verse they can connect a bunch of
different Spider-Mans together they can
do variants of Spider-Man but also
different versions of Spider-Man like
Miles Morales which they are doing in
across the spider verse right now they
can also have characters like Gwen Stacy
Spider Woman Felicia Hardy AKA Black Cat
and of course Venom the possibilities
for a true spider verse are essentially
almost endless but of course the big
question is will they do it and will
they do it correctly well as far as the
question goes of will they do it they
are already doing it make no mistake
Sony is setting up a spider-verse they
kind of already have except it didn't
really have that good of a plan now
luckily for us and for them it looks
like they have kind of abandoned their
old plans and the new plans that they
have coming up sound quite good and it
sounds like they are working really well
with Marvel Studios to where we won't
just have the Sony Spider-Man universe
but it could also connect to the MCU
with the Spider-Man characters that is
but at the same time you never really
know because we are in The multiversal
Saga and Venom Tom Hardy's Venom that is
could show up in Avengers Secret Wars in
fact I would be pretty disappointed if
he didn't show up but you really never
know with Sony and Marvel but like I
said it does look like they are on a
better track now with kind of abandoning
their old plan most should remember
their old plan with the super confusing
morbius post-credit scenes with Michael
Keaton's vulture all of a sudden being
in the Sony Universe with the Vegas
explanation ever to the point where they
might as well not have even said
anything at all and let us just guess
for a while it looked like they were
going to do a Sinister Six movie with
some of the characters from the MCU only
the Spider-Man films that is vulture
Scorpion and of course characters like
Venom who are in the Sony Spider-Man
universe now don't get me wrong I do
hope we get a Sinister Six movie
eventually but I'm glad that this
doesn't really seem to be the case
anymore you see it does seem like Sony
is indeed starting over with Madame Webb
Madam Webb in the comics is a cosmic
entity who can travel the Multiverse and
it looks like we are going to be seeing
that happen in Madame web in fact if a
alleged plot leak that was posted online
anonymously is true it sounds like it's
actually going to be pretty cool it
sounds like we're going to have a few
different versions of Spider-Woman
trying to protect Mary Parker and a baby
Peter Parker which sounds honestly
really cool and different and unique so
I hope they go that route and to top it
all off Sony has basically told us Miles
Morales in live action is coming and
what's funny is they actually kind of
gave us a time frame as well many people
know Amy Pascal who used to be the
chairperson over at Sony Pictures
Entertainment after that she started her
own production company called Pesco
pictures where she still works with Sony
to this day producing movies like the
Spider-Man homecoming Trilogy and she is
almost always an executive producer or a
producer for Sony films and she works
very closely with Kevin feige over at
Marvel Studios they worked together in
the past for a very long time and then
of course when Marvel Studios wanted to
do Spider-Man themselves in the MCU the
two of them are the ones who talked
about it in fact Amy Pascal called Kevin
feige in to try to help with the third
Andrew Garfield Amazing Spider-Man movie
which is where Kevin feige said hey it's
not gonna work you need to let
Spider-Man come to the MCU which
eventually did happen so the good news
is Sony Damian Pascal are open to reason
and she actually teased a live action
Miles Morales in a recent interview with
Empire when talking about if we are
going to be getting a live action Miles
Morales she said fans will have to wait
a couple of years to see what we do
that's a pretty big tease and kind of a
pretty decent confirmation that Miles
Morales in live action form is going to
be popping up in the MCU somewhere this
has been the rumor for a while that
Miles Morales is going to show up in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe most likely to
take over the mantle of the Spider-Man
in the MCU it's been reported that Tom
Holland has signed a new contract with
Marvel Studios for six additional movies
three of them will be solo Spider-Man
films the other three will be team-up
films so you have your Spider-Man
trilogy the new one then you have the
two Avengers films and then maybe one
more like Daredevil but after these Tom
Holland is most likely done as
Spider-Man he's basically stated before
that he doesn't want to be too old and
still playing Spider-Man not because he
doesn't love the character but just as
him being an actor for a career would
like to move on and do a lot of
different characters which is
understandable but that means Marvel
Studios is going to need a new
Spider-Man in the MCU but it's going to
need to be fresh not just the same thing
that we got before and Miles Morales
would be a perfect way to keep a
Spider-Man in the MCU but make it fresh
and what's interesting is we keep
looking at across the spider verse as
maybe a possible way to get a live
action Miles Morales in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe could it actually end
up being the same miles that we see in
across the spider-verse this discussion
has been going on more and more recently
since we've heard reports about Tom
Holland Spider-Man showing up in across
the spider-verse in fact Amy Pascal was
asked about this in that same interview
with Empire when asked about it she
laughed and she stated I am not going to
comment on anything around that but I
can tell you that Tom Holland does love
of those spider-verse movies now as I
mentioned we've had some reports from
some insiders stating that Tom Holland
is indeed going to be in the movie so in
theory and we love theories if Tom
Holland's Peter Parker Spider-Man can go
from the MCU into the spider-verse the
animated spider-verse then in theory
Miles Morales could go from the animated
spider-verse to the MCU that could
technically happen the question is would
that be the move and I don't believe it
would be of course with the spider-verse
there should be multiple versions of
Miles Morales just like there are
multiple versions of Peter Parker so I
think the best move would be to Simply
introduce a new Miles Morales in the new
Spider-Man trilogy not in the first
movie but maybe in the second movie and
then have him be kind of a prominent
character in the third movie that way
Tom Holland's Spider-Man can mentor him
and then eventually he can just take
over the mantle and from there the MCU
could get a lot more very unique
Spider-Man characters we could finally
introduce spider Gwen we could do block
cat we could do Jessica drew it all kind
of depends on how Sony wants to play
with Marvel but since they are
developing their own spider verse it
shouldn't be that big of a problem again
the only question is is Sony going to
link their live action spider verse with
their animated spider-verse which right
now is a question that we kind of don't
know yet but regardless of whether those
two universes connected does seem like
across the spider-verse is going to be
better than the first film which is kind
of hard to do sometimes and in that same
interview with Empire magazine Amy
Pascal recently told us this the danger
with a sequel is to go bigger just for
bigger's sake but all the bells and
whistles are no good unless you care
this movie is a love story between miles
and Gwen so it's nice to know that at
the core of this movie is going to be
the story it's not just a spider-verse
movie to throw a bunch of different
Spider-Man at us but they are focused on
the story while also giving us the
spider-verse which is awesome and
meanwhile it does look like we can
expect a live-action Miles Morales to
enter the MCU at some point in the next
handful of years and will all patiently
await to see what Sony is doing with
their live-action spider verse hopefully
it turns out really well but hey let us
know your thoughts about all of this in
the comments down below what do you
think please don't forget to hit that
like button and subscribe so you can
stay up to date on all the Spider-Man
news both in the MCU and in Sony
spider-verse you can also follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf